you may not be as speedy as him but
you'll definitely want to race as fast
as you can to see slide the Hedgehog on
the silver screen next year looper
recently spoke with Sonic the Hedgehog
composer Tom Holcomb Borg
also known as junkie XL who has scored
films like Deadpool Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice Mad Max fury road
Elita battle angel and the newly
released terminates a dark fate in
conversation we asked if there was
anything about Sonic that holcomb board
could tease without spilling spoilers of
course Vulcan Borg had some promising
words to share the only thing I can say
is that it turned out to be a really
really great film and it's so fun to
work on it really great characters
really lovely really cute at the same
time so I'm looking forward for that to
finish anticipation for the project
based on Sega's beloved video game
franchise of the same name has been
palpable from the minute Paramount
Pictures announced in October 2017 that
it would be fast tracking the film to
development hype continued to build in
February 2018 when paramount confirmed
Sonic the Hedgehog would race into
cinemas in November 2009 teen fans
finally got their look at the
long-awaited movie in a trailer that was
released in April 2019 when that footage
finally arrived however reception was
mixed at best and shockingly bad at
worse the majority of fans felt that the
most important component of Sonic the
Hedgehog Sonic himself liked a certain
something in his design as a CGI
character interacting with humans like
Jim Carrey's villainous super scientist
dr. Robotnik and James Madison's
friendly Montana Sheriff Tom wachowski
Sonic needed to look picture-perfect
many fans weren't completely satisfied
with the way Sonic appeared in the first
trailer for the film and paramount took
the criticisms and stride before making
an important decision shortly after the
unveiling of the first Sonic the
Hedgehog trailer director Jeff Fowler
announced that a special effects team
will be going back to the drawing board
to give Sonic a design overhaul he
tweeted in May 2019 thank you for the
support and the criticism the message is
loud and clear you aren't happy with the
design and you want changes it's going
to happen
everyone at Paramount and Sega are fully
committed to making this character the
best he can be the filmmakers
subsequently confirmed that the redesign
with delay the film which is now slated
to open in theaters on February 14th
2020 since then we've seen peaks of what
could be a possible sonic redesigned
floating around online with one photo
even showing the new sonic on an in
theatres promotional stand II the snap
suggests that the Sonic the Hedgehog
teams on a bang-up job improving the
character's appearance in fact it looks
like the design team were quickly able
to give fans basically everything they
could want from the rework design the
conversation surrounding the original
Sonic design was mixed at best some fans
seemed to the lighting collectively
roasting the characters original movie
design poking fun at his creepy human
teeth and odd body proportions while
some fans are somewhat more positive
that still left paramount with a pretty
clear indication that fans weren't
daring to be happy when the photos of
the alleged redesign surfaced on social
media many who are initially critical of
Sonic the Hedgehog changed their tune
complimenting the new design and
admitting that they were keen to see the
new film one even wrote on Twitter that
the purported visual update Sonic
received that so incredible the other
team's handling Sonic related content
and products could stand to learn a
thing or two from the Sonic the Hedgehog
film team they wrote movie Sonic's
redesign is so good it even makes a
modern sonic design from the games look
bland in comparison it's clear that
everyone involved with Sonic the
Hedgehog is working fast to create a
satisfying final product and based on
what some holcomb blog told us the film
is going to be more than worth it in the
end
Sonic the Hedgehog will hit theaters on
February 14th 2020 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos buy your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
you